well forget that window-dressing of red
carpets and showbiz parties there new
figures today revealing that the UK's
creative industries were worth a record
seventy six point nine billion pounds to
the British economy in 2013 the last
year for which figures were available
it's the fastest growing sector and
that's why they're playing a key role in
the government's long-term economic plan
now when we talk about the creative
industries we mean a lot of different
sectors architecture advertising crafts
design film games publishing museums and
galleries music technology and
television and look at this the
contribution which they make creative
industries make is almost 10 percent
between 2012 and 2013 three times faster
than that of the wider UK economy and
topping the list compared to the other
industries such as professional support
the next biggest so within business
management law agriculture forestry and
fishing very much worse actually
contracting by naught percent and
combined the creative industries are
worth just under seventy seven billion
pounds a year and if we break it down by
sector we can see that far and away the
highest is IT software and computer
services then there is advertising
marketing and what we're seeing is that
an eight point three billion pounds from
advertising to ten point two billion in
2013 publishing actually isn't far
behind them then film TV radio
photography followed by music forming
arts and visual arts and interestingly
architecture and crafts have remained
static now when it comes to jobs the
creative industries a makeup account for
5.6 percent of all UK jobs the consumer
industry was easily the sector's
biggest employers we can see they're
securing 825,000 jobs
advertising and marketing next with 482
thousand jobs right down to crafts the
smaller sector in the group but still
nearly a hundred thousand jobs there
well Sir William Sargent joins me now
he's the CEO and co-founder of
Framestore which won an Oscar for visual
effects for the film gravity in 2014 and
also here with me at John Mavis who's
CEO of the Design Council and dr.
Charles Soule Marez Smith who's the
chief executive of the Royal Academy of
Arts welcome to all of you it's William
Sargent a great success story then the
fastest growing segment of the economy
does that come as a surprise to you or
do you feel like you're in a very
dynamic sector at the moment well we
felt like this for the past decade it
has been the fastest growing sector
economy it's only just now that people
are realizing this is a real business a
serious place for kids to have their
careers in and so forth and so it's very
sort of good that we're seeing this sort
of a success story share it properly now
and they in the economic terms but why
is it happening I mean your particular
area of the industry does enjoy certain
tax breaks doesn't it is it because of
that is it because of government help
that this industry if you look at the
wider sector creative including film and
television which I men were very good at
it here in the UK there's something
about the lateral thinking the ability
to sort of make things their unique and
different which the world connects with
and it's all about connecting with
people we connect very well with the
world Joe made us would you agree do you
think Britain is an inherently creative
nation yeah I think we've always been an
ideas nation and I think increasingly we
are an ideas nation I think the
investment in education exactly as
you've said is is the key to it and it's
thing is the key to making sure that we
continue to be successful I'm if
anything I'm worried that we're not
investing enough and making the
connections between culture and
creativity so that we can continue to to
grow the industry in the way that we've
seen in the last expound on that a
little bit what are your main concerns
that there's not enough focus on the
arts at university well I think there's
been a huge amount of work and I'm sure
colleagues will confirm this that
between the links between culture and
our exposure to culture as as as we grow
through education and the links into the
creative industries and we've got to
make sure that the government is very
supportive of the that flow through of
knowledge and information so that so
that our creative industry can have the
talent that we need to make sure that we
can continue the success okay dr.
Charles Smith I mean today your view on
that just to pick up on that do you
think that education it's your share the
anxiety correctly because well after all
the current government has concentrated
on the so-called STEM subjects science
technology engineering and mathematics
they've not really talked about and
concentrated on the development of the
arts I think what was said earlier about
British education traditionally being
about questioning and intelligence and
creativity I'm not convinced that still
is central to the way people are talk
now and actually the productivity and
the effectiveness and the wealth
internationally of British visual arts
architecture may not have grown but if
you think of Norman Foster rich Rogers
pris Wilkinson Nick Grimshaw they are
global figures and they're incredibly
important to the way Britain is
perceived they emerge from a 1960s
architectural culture at the
architectural Association which was very
very much about creativity and I don't
think this government I'm not convinced
any government has really got that
aspect of the link between creative
education and the creative economy
that's the good thing about this report
another concern perhaps for you I don't
know is about the funding of the Arts as
well we've talked about some of the tax
breaks that are offered some areas of
the creative industries but what about
some concern that has been expressed
about cuts that art funding is that
something your case I think they're
worries of course one of the sectors
mentioned are museums galleries and
libraries libraries particularly I think
are declining
their cuts both in central government
funding but also local authority funding
and you get this curious mixture of the
big museums in London being
the dynamic and very successful bringing
in cultural tourism but look at the big
Central Library in Birmingham which
opened only a couple of years ago
they're now talking about having to
reduce stuff radically and that whole
idea of having a very visible public
monument claim of where people have
access to knowledge suddenly you spend a
lot of money and then two years later
everybody is saying it it's not working
well yes and sorting sergeant the
government has talked about tourism
being part of the money that the part of
the reason for the creative industries
of boosting the economy that the way it
brings people in to what extent do your
different areas bounce off each other do
you create a kind of creative britain
plc to a certain extent and feed off
each other's reputation if you look at
the exports is about 18 billion a year
so if you add the exports together with
the inward visiting as well as the
perception of the UK because you know
the UK's perceived as right at the sharp
edge of what's good and clever you look
at Apple for example with a you know
creative head there and so forth who's
British you know that allows us then to
go into business in the rest of the
world so it's not it's it's it's
intangible qualities that actually have
been very good for us when we go to
China to try to sell our services or the
United States we start with the fact
that Britain's perceived as world-class
and the creative industries are
generally the most visible aspect of
that but are you concerned about losing
this lead that you have I mean how
competitive are the industries that
you're in but you'd be incredibly
competitive in realism it's tough to
hang on to that kind of growth it's two
things we were competitive within
ourselves my two of my four main
competitors are within hundred yards of
me in London so so that's really good
but you know in the g20 community so to
speak the other countries you know China
India places like that know the creative
engineers is a very good thing it's very
good for an economy is very good for a
society they would like a piece of that
and so we look at 10 years and we got
some serious competition would yet still
make this how worried are you about
other countries snapping at your heels
well I think it's it's interesting I
mean the design industry in the UK is
the the second largest and second
largest design industry in the whole
world with the largest in Europe and
that's a heritage that we've had from
any many
years but you look at something like
China for instance and you're talking
about China China traditionally has been
no one over the last number of years for
being made in China there's a real
movement nowadays to be talking about
being designed in China and that that is
quite worrying because you know China
has hundreds of thousands of designers
graduating every year and we've got to
make sure that the exactly the things
that they my colleagues were talking
about that make us different and better
are continually continually promoted and
supported and I'll put this question to
you because James Dyson comes from the
design area he's expressed some concerns
about Home Secretary's plans to to limit
the amount of time international
students can stay in the country once
they've graduated he was concerned about
the impact but could have it and do you
have any issues without yourself he
talked about education
well I'm very keen that that people can
come and be trained and stay and work in
this country and that the talent flow
should be both ways I mean exactly to
the point that you know many of the the
world's largest corporations actually
have British design at their head so
Johnny I've as many people might not
know it's a British designer trained in
Newcastle responsible in many ways for
apples success and I can reel off
countless other designers who exactly
the same position in corporations around
them okay last very quick question to
dr. Charles so Mary Smith how to Mystic
are you for the future
unfortunately that it's you of allowing
people to come I mean they're too rather
uncomfortable aspects to this one is
London is key because London has
generated a lot of the design industry
in Shoreditch Hoxton and everything it's
the center of it the other thing is it's
incredibly multicultural I mean the
whole I think a fluorescence of the
design industries in this country over
the last 20 years has depended precisely
on the influx of international ideas
thought through postgraduate education
the fact that now if you study here
you're immediately sent back to your
home country is potentially very very
damaging okay we must leave it there
this discussion could go on and on but
we must leave it there gentlemen thank
you all very much indeed
thank you